So, now that we have seen how two or more bit histories work, let's do a
quiz about them. Let's say we have an
N-BIT History, with a 2-BIT counter per history in
each predictor entry. Let's say that we need
1,024 entries in order for each branch to,
and each other instruction, to have its own
entry, so that they don't interfere with each other.
So, for the length of the history of 1, 4, 8 and 16, what
is the cost of the entire predictor in bits? I'm going to
tell you that the cost with a 1-BIT of History is the
1-BIT History, and two 2-bit counters per entry.
So it's going to 5 bits times 1024. Is this
predictor good for each of the predictors for a pattern of N N N T that
repeats. And we know already that the 1-bit
history predictor is not good for this pattern because
it's too long for it. And finally what is the number of two bit counters in an
entry that we actually use when trying to
predict the repeating NT pattern? Meaning not taken, taken,
not taken, taken and so on. We already know that
in the N equals 1 predictor we need to both of our counters, so the
answer is 2. To further help you, I'm going to tell you that the
cost of N equals 4 predictor should be. The history is 4
plus 2 bit predictors I need 2 to the 4th on that
times 1,024. You can compute what this is,
you should put the real number here. So
you should multiply things out for these two,
here, you should just say yes or no.
Yes, if the predictor will predict this successfully
after the initial warmup period. Now, if it
want, and then how many two-bit counters are
we using for the not taken, taken, not taken,
taken pattern in this particular predictor.